merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
rien ne va plus dans le royaume de
france c'est un peu la cour du roi
pétaud où sont les sully ou sur les cool
berre où sont les turgot le 22 janvier à
davos devant le parterre des femmes et
des hommes les plus riches du monde
votre ministre monsieur macron annoncé à
grand renfort médiatique que les 35
heures était morte que le taux de
majoration des heures supplémentaires
n'avaient plus lieu d'être que la
prochaine loi sur le travail
supprimerait les planchers de majoration
hourra chez les plus libéraux deux jours
plus tard la lecture du rapport ban
adhère vous ajoutiez vous même à la
cacophonie ambiante en indiquant que la
durée légale de 35 heures serait
inscrite en préambule de la loi
pourquoi pas de la constitution et que
les heures supplémentaires seraient bien
majoré sans préciser d'ailleurs le
nombre d'heures concernés cerise sur le
gâteau la semaine dernière votre vie
c'est du travail van hamel comrie
rappelait qu'il n'était pas question de
revenir sur la majoration des heures
supplémentaires et encore moins
d'organiser des référendums d'entreprise
et puis patatras qu patatras qui hier la
même ministre indique vouloir intégrer
la possibilité d'un référendum
contraignant dans les entreprises pour
valider les accords sur le temps de
travail et le président de la république
dans tout ça lors de ses voeux au
conseil économique c bien ses propres
déclarations qui ont ouvert la boîte de
pandore du psychodrame gouvernementale
alors monsieur le premier disque y
croire monsieur macron vous-même ou
madame l conneries
les français sont en réalité plus
préoccupés vous en conviendrez de la
crise économique et du chômage
grandissant que de la réforme
territoriale de la réforme du collège ou
même de la réforme constitutionnelle
ils ont bien compris eux que les emplois
dépendent pour la plus grande part de
nos pme que ce n'est pas l'effet
d'aubaine des 2000 euros dont voulait
les gratifier pour des emplois souvent
précaires qui va changer la donne les
entreprises monsieur le prémice demande
de la clarté pour retrouver ce qu'on
appelle la confiance
cette confiance qui vous manque tant
aujourd'hui monsieur prémices pas
question est donc simple
serez-vous enfin capable au bout de
quatre ans du gouvernement et bientôt à
la veille de l'échéance présidentielle
de redonner un espoir pour nos chômeurs
monsieur le premier ministre
entendez-vous enfin yves serez vous
capable de me dire attention réelle
terme notre code premier ministre
manuel valls sur le président
l'assemblée mus monsieur le monsieur le
député vous avez raison c'est la
confiance qu'il faut en permanence
entretenir restauré pour ce qui concerne
nos entreprises c'est le sens
c'est le sens du pacte de responsabilité
de solidarité du cic eux de la volonté
qui est celle cette majorité depuis 2012
de donner davantage de compétitivité à
nos entreprises puisque pendant des
années nous avons perdu cette
compétitivité notamment dans la
comparaison le différentiel avec
l'allemagne en baissant bien sûr le coût
du travail
il faut en permanence réformer s'adapter
nous avons souhaité engager d'ailleurs
depuis plusieurs mois la réforme du code
du travail s'est pas attaquée depuis
déjà de nombreuses années en partant
d'abord des principes et c'est tout le
travail que robert badinter avec sans
doute les meilleurs experts dans ce
domaine là à mener et il est toujours
bon de rappeler quels sont les principes
et les droits dont les salariés les
travailleurs de ce pays doivent
bénéficier
et donc nous intégrerons dans le texte
de loi que prépare myriam el khomri ses
principes et ce projet de loi qu'elle
prépare au delà du compte personnel
d'activité qui fait l'objet aujourd'hui
de discussions difficiles avec les
partenaires sociaux et je regrette la
position prise par le patronat ce stade
mais je ne désespère pas que les
partenaires sociaux avancent au delà de
ce chapitre là le reste sera abordée
c'est à dire l'organisation du temps de
travail mais monsieur le député il ya
quelques principes simples qui sont
rappelées d'ailleurs par robert badinter
et ça fait partie du débat d'aujourd'hui
pour demain est-ce qu'il faut une durée
légale
normal pour reprendre le terme de ces
experts du temps de travail
oui ou non il en faut une c'est ce que
nous pensons aujourd'hui elle est de
trente cinq heures hier
elle a été de 39 heures mais il faut une
durée si vous voulez qu'il n'y ait pas
de durée légale du temps de travail il
faut le dire même si vous le savez la
durée effective est aujourd'hui de 39
heures donc il faut une durée s'il y a
des heures supplémentaires faute elle
qu'elle soit payer davantage que les
heures normales
oui c'est un deuxième principe qui
rappelait par robert badinter et son
comité
mais nous sommes nous attacher et à la
durée légale du temps de travail
aujourd'hui à 35 heures et à la
majoration des heures supplémentaires
par ailleurs nous souhaitons davantage
de souplesse dans l'entreprise monsieur
le député le cas de smart a été de ce
point de vue là particulièrement
intéressant ce sont des sujets
extrêmement compliqué comme la majorité
qui doit permettre un accord ou pas
c'est toutes ces questions là qui ont
été abordés par milliards mêmes
conneries
elle a eu tout à fait raison de rappeler
que le référendum pouvait aussi être une
solution
donc les choses avancent monsieur le
député mais comme moi je suis très
attentif à l'ensemble des publications
elles sont nombreuses aujourd'hui dans
les différentes librairies de notre pays
je remarque qu'il y à de nombreux mets à
culpa notamment sur le fait que pendant
dix ans contrairement ce que vous avez
raconté est ce que vous osez proposé
aujourd'hui même si je n'ai pas entendu
beaucoup de propositions dans ma bouche
c'est vous mêmes vous n'avez jamais
toucher aux 35 heures il ya eu des
assouplissements
mais vous n'avez jamais remis en cause
et les 35 heures et la durée légale du
travail
donc le problème c'est pas le passé
c'est de constater que nous réformons
mais avec des principes et en tenant
compte de la situation et des
entreprises pour qu'elles aient
davantage de souplesse et des salariés
pour qu'ils aient tous les droits
nécessaires et devant le pays dit
clairement les choses
voulez vous remettre oui ou non en cause
la durée légale du temps de travail
voulez-vous non majoré les heures
supplémentaires soyez clair vous à votre
tour
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à mme ce genre net